nie ja nie planowałem kandydować
ale poproszono
że nadeżyła się okazja czy była
oferta nie do odrzucenia
żeby wesprzeć Po prostu listę
żeby razem jako zespół lepszy wynik yy
zdobyć może więcej głosów
no pewnie mam jakiś swój elektorat
yy i tyle ale pan będzie realnie walczył w tej kampanii
czy pan Po prostu użycza swojego nazwiska na liście
no ja zawsze kiedy no kandyduję
no to realnie walczę w sensie
że no gdyby się zdarzyło
że zostanę wybrany to
no to nie brzmi Jak
nie brzmi Jak pewność
to ten mandat przyjmę
natomiast chyba się nie zanosi
ja jakoś no tak Jak mówię nie planowałem
nie jestem jakoś szczególnie
przygotowany do prowadzenia ekstensywnej kampanii
coś Tam spróbuję na miarę możliwości